[Music]
welcome back to another episode of whato
Prof hello Walter Martin this is getting
very
boring but I see the the news anchors
they have the same tune the whole time
so I'm just sticking with it I'm I'm
neither an anchor nor news
[Laughter]
well after our last
episode finally we get some time to
speak about the science and and some
health yeah we we've been threatening
for a long time but we never get there
yeah seems like this is a trend that's
going on we every time want to get to
something but something happens and you
can't get there yeah but now we're there
so let's open with a word of
prayer our heavenly father thank you
again for bringing us together Lord as
always we ask that you please bless this
discussion Enlighten our minds and help
us to discern the right from wrong in
Jesus name amen
amen Martin you've put a strange Title
Here Comes of course from a Bible verse
surely our fathers have inherited
lives uh you know the devil is the
father of lies right yes he was a liar
from the beginning and the truth is not
in him
and uh so much of what we experience in
life is based on
lies unfortunately that's true yes
unfortunately it is Jeremiah 16:1 19 oh
Lord my strengthen my Fortress and my
refuge in the day of
Affliction the Gentiles shall come unto
thee from the ends of the Earth and
shall say surely our fathers have
inherited lies
vanity and things wherein there is no
profit what that's an amazing
verse so
unbelievers will in the end come to
Believers and
say we've been running on
lies correct yeah it's amazing I mean if
you just think about the issues now I
love science
and uh I was a science
fanatic you know when when kids read
comics and stuff like this I would read
science books I used to take them out of
the library I think I've said that
before is to drive my poor mother up the
wall my room was a total disaster with
attempts at building telescopes to look
at the stars can I it wasn't a disaster
it was just a science experiment it was
a science experiment I would have insect
colonies in my house I would have cans
full of different Critters and
worms and uh Optics and chemicals and
bomb constructions and it was a
disaster and my mother died when I was
12 so I don't know even know how old I
was then maybe seven or eight just being
able to read so I've always been
interested in
science and when I went to the
university and I studied
science this was my
Fascination now people always like when
I talk about issues always say oh he's a
zoologist yeah yeah that when I talk
about theology he's a theolog he's a
theologist what does a zoologist know
about that yes I studied zoology but I
was actually studying comparative
physiology which is a branch of
zoology and comparative physiology means
that you are comparing the physiology of
every creature on the
planet including humans including
humans so in many a Medical
Faculty uh comparative animal
physiologists fit in
perfectly because number one they have
studied animal physiology they have
studied human
physiology their
experimentation takes place in the
animal realm mhm because the general
trend is that you don't use humans as
guinea pigs unless of course you're
living in our time when it seems to be
the norm now to use humans as guinea
pigs yeah in the past you know humans
could volunteer for certain experiments
but then they had to sign certain forms
that they were willing to do this now
you become a guinea pig door too I know
it's very interesting how the world has
changed yeah yeah but in any case my
research was done on
animals and uh when you study human
physiology then the animal model is the
one that is custom used in science so
you either use a rat you use a rabbit
and people will say they're not exactly
the same so then you work with veret
monkeys and you try and get as close to
the human model as possible and this is
the research that I was involved in all
of my
life and uh for the last years of my
University career I was in a Medical
Faculty so a professor of medical
bioscience M so these people who would
like to use the label zoologist in a
derogatory fashion or a degrading
fashion yeah and most of the times the
people that use it D it
derogatory don't even know what it means
no they haven't got the foggiest idea of
what it means because you know if you
say someone is a
zoologist if you are somehow in the no
then you would ask well what is your
field of speciality
are you an ecologist are you an
environmentalist are you an anatomist
are you a whatever a physiologist are
you a
taxonomist it depends what your
specialization
is so there there are so many aspects to
science and so many labels and it
becomes so specialized that sometimes
you concentrate your entire career on
one tiny minuscule
aspect and it somehow has to fit into
the big
picture so if you want to be a
comparative physiologist you have to
study the
insect if you go too deeply into that
well then you are no longer in that
particular field but you go into the
field of Entomology
and that again has a lot of
subcategories so science is a is a very
broad broad
name and a
scientist is an interesting
phenomena because when it comes to the
field of
science they use the Regal wi M the
Regal we in other words we discovered
it's never I discovered science we know
mhm who's the we we is plural right
correct so we know that whatever it
is so whatever let's say we know that
aids is derived from a virus the HIV
virus we know who's the we all
scientists all scientists so there's
some where is somewhere something that
fits into this category of we and we is
such a big word that immediately it
lends
support to whatever you are saying if
you say I say MH then it's an individual
yes but when you come up against that
big word we mhm then it becomes very
very important right now what if the we
is wrong yes then is it you that's wrong
or is it the whole we that's
wrong the whole we the all we all right
so you come to the
university and you study evolutionary
biology it's part of the subject of
zoology now uh Dr foui is constantly
referring to his evolutionary
biologists and uh the anti-conspiracy
theory won't call them zoologists yeah
but in fact that's exactly what they
should be because zoology is the mother
of The evolutionary theory right correct
not botany because you can't prove it
from botany so you have to use zoology
so you have another category
evolutionary scientists and these are
very prominent in the medical sphere in
the world today and they're part of the
we now when you study this theory of
evolution
and then later you
come to study this
book there's a conflict of interests
right yeah a serious conflict of
interest and so science that wants to
marry religion and science MH will say
uh we can compromise on this issue we
can have theistic Evolution
yeah you cannot have that you cannot
have theistic evolution
because you cannot have a system of
death providing the impetus for the Next
Generation in the survival of the
fittest scenario to come up with the
final product which is Humanity yeah
when the scripture clearly says that
death is a consequence of sin exactly
and not a means of progression to
something greater so never ever would
you be able to have the Plan of
Salvation
of a god becoming man and dying to give
you eternal
life which is nonsensical because death
was there from the beginning whereas
according to the scripture death is an
interposition yeah something that came
in
afterwards so the two philosophies don't
mix and if you want to mix them well
then you're a very confused scientist
correct and there are many of
many theistic
evolutionists uh they have the plant
world living without the Sun for
billions of years yeah yeah it's totally
ludicrous and unfortunately it's ented
religion correct and they have a world
where you have a reducing atmosphere no
oxygen but you have to have
water in order to develop the molecules
of life
if you don't have oxygen in the
atmosphere then you don't have an ozone
layer if you don't have an ozone layer
you have radiation if you have radiation
then you produce oxygen by splitting
water into oxygen and hydrogen so you
cannot have an atmosphere without oxygen
if you have
water these people are very confused
right and when you start realizing that
then you come to the point where science
clashes with
itself and when you switch your
philosophy of
science does that mean you have
eradicated science no no of course not
but you have come into a position of
clash of
Minds when it comes to the philosophy of
science all right yes now this is
something we need to talk about because
the philosophy of science is not
necessarily the science correct and we
talk about the theory of
evolution or we talk about whatever the
molecular theories we talk about Theory
Theory Theory Theory yeah or cellular
Theory relativity Theory what the cell
looks like
okay and every few years it changes yeah
because knowledge increases right and
theories have to be modified the theory
is not a fact yeah when you listen to
some scientists especially the
evolutionary scientists and evolution is
a fact M so they start off with an
axium that evolution is a fact yeah but
what if it's a
fable then your whole theory is
incorrect right right now when you talk
about viruses in the time that we are
living in then does evolution play a
part yes absolutely because all the
variant are as a result of evolution
right
yeah when you unpack that at the genetic
level you will find that a lot of what
we know is based on pure conjecture
correct and not based on truth but it
has to be
hidden in the package of the we know
correct and is sold to humanity as a
fact as a fact
yeah
right has anybody ever
really produced the virus of any kind
and said here it is no is there such a
publication no much of it is based on
computer
modeling right and it is is still in the
realm of
theory correct no matter how
plausible and future knowledge could
change things right so in the past many
many infectious
diseases were treated in the most
drastic
Fashions and people were deprived of
their
children because they had infectious
diseases when in fact they had a
nutritional
malady yeah
scurvy if you arrived here with bleeding
gums and teeth falling out I would think
you have a terrible disease I certainly
if I was a lady would not like to give
you a kiss I might catch it whatever you
had right but it's just the vitamin C
deficiency and then you had
rickets and all of these diseases they
were nutritional dis diseases but they
were all classified as infectious
diseases at one stage yeah so knowledge
is an amazing thing science is an
amazing thing I we can carry on forever
talking in this line without getting to
one single slide and we don't want to do
that yeah but the point is
this science is a
passion but science isn't necessarily
based on
truth you could have inherited lies yeah
and I want to go so far as to say that
every first grader who goes to school
inherits lies from the very first day
that he sits on a
school desk yes he's fed
Evolution he's fed science of whatever
nature cosmology for example do we
really know whether we derived from a
big bang or not just because some Jesuit
says that we are from a big
bang is that necessarily truth and
that's the only one that they get these
days they don't get the alternative
correct now what about all the other
Sciences now
Martin I was involved in the science of
nutrition that was my field
to to our critics who would say
zoologist yeah I was studying uh
nutritional
physiology and I was reasonably
successful in what I was doing but it
was contrary to everything that the
world stands for yes you were it was
diametrically
opposed and it was almost impossible to
get funding for my research correct no
matter what my academic status
was until I plotted and plotted and
plotted until I finally got it
recognized as a legitimate field of
research it was a
war literally a
war with even sabotage attempts against
the research that was being done yeah it
was amazing but it was eventually
recognized and uh I was a recipient of a
grant from the Royal Society London
which is very very
prestigious which again brought with it
of course many other pitfalls and
enemies because why should someone with
such strange research be even granted
such a privilege
and uh it comes with a couple of perks
you meet uh some very high People You
Meet the
Lords for example and have um lunch with
them so it it has uh the upside but it
has the downside too because of the
funding that is channeled into your
research
projects uh you have to work like a
doctor
so the only reward that you have is your
scientific
recognition that is not a monetary award
reward associated with it it comes with
a lot of hard work yeah and if you're
controversial in your science such as I
was you have
problems because the world sees
nutrition human nutrition from an
evolutionary standpoint correct correct
so in other words we evolved our
intelligence
yes does that sound academic we evolved
our
intelligence because we became Predators
yeah and we're not very fast on our
legs and so we have to develop mean
means in order to outwit the animals out
there in order to put them on our plate
and consume them yes right so a
carnivore tends to be more
intelligent than a herbivore so they say
so they
say have you ever studied the
intelligence of
birds incredible what they're capable of
and and they eat plants seeds
right some of them of course eat insects
and other things and and the birds of
prey but
uh it is a notion that you're going to
be more intelligent because you have to
out witht somebody all
right and uh that is how the human
species evolved to whatever status it
has arrived this super intelligent being
and on that basis they work nutrition
correct if you take the Bible it tells
you the the exact opposite mhm so which
one is
right right definitely the Bible science
says You must base your lifestyle on
animal products so you have the basic
four diet which consists of your Dairy
your meat your plant-based things your
fruits your nuts and seeds and what have
you and now today we know that that is
totally incorrect right well it's still
a war it's still a war but there have
been other scientists like Dr Campbell
yes in The China Study and uh huge
studies on vegetarianism Etc which prove
the point so that even the World Health
Organization has to acknowledge it
whether they like it or not
right so it was a war and we'll talk
about that war a little bit later why
was there a
war because the mindset of the science
the we the we did not fit with the
eye yeah all right and uh if you want to
be a recognized scientist you better be
part of the Wii that's it otherwise
you're going to be on your own you're
going to be on your own you're going to
be an ey so this statement is very true
I think many a gentile unbeliever will
come at the end and say I think we've
inherited lies yes can you please
enlighten us those that have studied
God's word and tell us how must I
survive the diseases that I am
confronted with every single day of my
life and the medical world cannot help
me anymore I'm in big big trouble help
me definitely I think we're on that
precipice right now you think so yeah
okay do you think about the philosophy I
didn't come from from the lower
creatures I didn't crawl out of the
Slime you mean I was created in the
image of God unless God is slime right
correct I had a royal origin had a royal
origin can you please correct the lies
on this
issue so what's on my plate can you
correct that so I can get rid of these
ailments and diseases that I'm suffering
from is that going to happen Martin yes
what about the
philosophies that are out there
concerning the billions of years and uh
all of these
issues so we have inherited lies so
Martin tell us about a very prominent
scientist for the times that we are
living in a noell prize
winner and uh we have a couple of things
we want to talk about and we will see
what this man had to say yeah it was
interesting to when I've we always get
some information from our viewers or so
and they sent me one of Carrie Mullis he
was the inventor of the PCR test I sure
that almost everybody on the planet
knows what that is today because that's
what being used to test if you are
positive or negative for Corona virus
correct so he's the inventor of that and
that's what he received the Nobel Prize
for yes but he's deceased now he's
deceased died in
2019 of a respiratory disease yes and
there was an interview that he had with
Gary null that also is a PhD yes and I
took some interesting Snips out of that
that we can discuss so we will discuss
what what he found now he is an
interesting fellow because he also was a
square peg in a round hole right he
didn't quite fit in and so the
establishment didn't like him in the end
and so he didn't receive the best of
press and they tried to trash His
science
yeah now I can sympathize with that
because uh having been in that same
boat uh I can concur with many things
that he says so let's look at a couple
of things and then we'll talk talk about
yeah I just want to put it there it's
the same that you said earlier when
you're not forming part of the we you
then you're like you said a square in
round now it's interesting that most of
the great inventors of Truth not
philosophy mostly didn't fit into the wi
correct do you believe that we have made
science
our final Arbiter in what is right and
as a result we continue to look at
Science And scientists hold themselves
up to make the decision that this is
right Behavior that's wrong Behavior you
can do this you can't do that it's a
good question and it's and I think the
answer is definitely that science in a
way having led to this sort of decline
of the of the of let's say the
Protestant church I mean we Protestants
got a little bit too involved in history
and left themselves open there for
scientists to come in and say it's a
debunk Christianity because it became a
mythological kind of thing rather than a
than a only by faith kind of thing and
you know it became a it's not a real
religion in a sense of of like Buddhism
or something science having been
involved in that people said well we're
not going to go to church anymore it
left a big hole in a lot of people's
psychological makeup that has I think
been filled to some degree by the
ecological Madness that people have got
jumped into and there the scientists are
like you say they are they are
considered the final Arbiters of what's
good for the planet or what's bad for
the planet and and they hadn't got the
slightest idea instead of wearing white
robes they wear white lab coats you know
instead of like com bringing you the
word of God they bring you the word of
the the EPA or whatever and and and they
don't have to understand what it is that
they are making you do in fact and
people you know just I think they fall
naturally into it because there there is
a need in in humanity for something like
a religion or just like in the 17th
century they decided to stop talking
about God in science it was too
complicated it started a war you know I
mean we start you get Catholicism gets
confused with science you have trouble
and I think here we've got similar kind
of problem we've got a a religious
phenomena almost a a large segment of
the pop ation that has very strong
opinions about something and
beliefs right I mean that's a religious
kind of a thing and it's Tangled Up With
Science it needs to be untangled the way
to untangle it is to use the analytic
kind of method that we used before pick
them apart don't talk about this overall
disease called
Aid well Martin that is a very
interesting opening discussion there so
we're pitting two entities against each
other the one is religion and the other
one is science
MH according to him science seems to
have won that battle Yeah and pushed
protestantism and religion into the
Realms of
Mythology and people are without an
anchor correct drifting on a
sea
now we have a statement in the spirit of
Prophecy that says that science rightly
understood mhm will not be in disharmony
with the word of God definitely all
right and this was my great problem when
I
started realizing that the word of God
was based on
truth I didn't start with Genesis I
would have ridiculed it into the middle
of next week
mhm prophecy took the carpet out from
underneath
me prophecy
yeah prophecy convinced me that God was
speaking and if God was speaking then
why was he lying about the
beginning correct right he first had to
get trust correct so started with
prophecy and ended up with
Genesis now
Genesis was a major catastrophe to me I
can imagine because it uh totally
destroyed my credibility at the
University with
most do you know that I had some secret
discussions with many a scientist in my
office many a scientist in my
office secret so that nobody should
know I had one
Dean a dean of
science come to me and say
what you are saying is the
truth and I know that you are right but
I will never support you
publicly and he
didn't he sat in one of my
lectures and he was one of the
adjudicators almost like a
debate and they asked him what he
thought about what I said
and he lambasted it and said you
know nonsense total
nonsense but secretly in my
office secretly he would admit to
something else and know this this really
stunned me to see how deep rooted the
religion of science exactly goes it is
so deep that it will uproot the word of
God even in the
Christian it's a sad State of Affairs it
is and as he says we have switched the
robe of the priest for the white coat of
the laboratory yeah and very often that
white coat is hiding behind a we mhm
that he doesn't know about now we have
two we here
we have the we of the Bible yeah let us
make we will right that's God speaking
and we have science that says we know
yeah when you know nothing exactly
because the more you know the more you
learn the more you know that you know
nothing yeah because science is so deep
that whenever you open one page there's
another page if you dig down to that
level there's another level
correct and it's like the microscopic
World it has to be because who's the
who's the main scientist correct no no
matter what you look at if you look at
the micro world and you go down down
down down down and eventually you come
to the electron
microscope they still haven't seen a
virus yeah it's still a computer model
right correct and so you go to the macro
world and you go up and goes bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and
endless There's No Limit no there is no
limit and you will never reach it no
because no matter how big your telescope
there's always something Beyond its
reach correct because the creator of it
is bigger than that bigger and so he's
absolutely right we've changed one
religion for another and that religion
is going to rule the world World
especially in the days that we are
living in the scientists are saying so
the politicians are saying so and the
churches are saying so correct listen to
the science that is the phrase that you
hear the whole time we have to listen to
the science correct in our previous
WhatsApp we even showed that even in the
movies they say that science will be the
Savior all right now again I want to
reiterate I too am a Scientist yeah
irrespective of what the ICS want to say
and I am a lover of
science but there is an aspect of
science which is based on nothing less
than
lies or at the best
conjecture shall we continue
yes state agencies have taken kids away
from parents when the parent based upon
informed knowledge chose not to give
their child either act or other
chemotherapy agents either for AIDS or
cancer and these were parents who knew
more than the average parent and based
upon their knowledge made it an informed
choice and those parents were deemed
unfit and abusive parents and their kids
were taken put into a foster home I you
know what in the in the 19th early 20th
century actually late 19th century in
the South pgra was thought to be a an
infectious disease it was a lack of
nasin because Southerners were eating
corn instead of wheat po four farmers
were and they were taking kids out of
house homes there thinking it was an
infectious disease cuz everybody in the
family was getting it put the kids in an
orphanage in the orphanage the kid would
get a little bit of niin because they'd
have some wheat and he wouldn't get pgra
so it made real sense took some guy you
know I took him a government research
station in South Carolina finally got a
a somebody some Goldberg some Jewish guy
came down there with a little brains and
said wait a minute this is not
infectious disease you know it's
somebody had to they had to throw out
all the idiots that were running that
but that was a long it was a long time
and they did the same thing they took
kids out of homes all they needed to do
was bring in a little bread a little
little whole wheat bread and does it
bother you at all every time we need a
decision made we're always looking for
some scientist to tell us what to do
whether it's on cancer or almost any
issue we're science science becomes has
become a state religion I it does it
bothers me when when I see like um
people you know my mother's a good
example of doing that so of just you
know the her doctors are never
questioned at all even though her son is
is sort of a medical person himself and
sometimes disagrees with him because I'm
her son of course I don't have any
brains There Are People Dying just
because of
a I mean that's that's proven in big
studies big studies like the concrete
study the conclusion of the concrete
study was this stuff is not not good for
you you know the little Skeleton on the
little crossbars crossbones the you know
the skeleton and crossbones on on on the
bottle says probably wouldn't be a good
idea to take the stuff unless you've got
a good reason to now there I would say
that probably you you know there've been
I don't know how many of the people who
have died so-called of AIDS have
actually died of a because it certainly
would backck your immune system to take
that stuff for a few years it's like if
you started taking any other
chemotherapy IC agent for the rest of
your life it would be that agent
probably that killed you you know when
you give chemotherapy to somebody with
cancer you give them a round of it for
maybe 14 days or a few days hopefully
you're not going to kill the patient
you're going to kill the cancer
patient's going to survive but you don't
keep giving it to him until he dies
because he certainly will and a is just
like those things it's a little more
lethal have we photographed AIDS do we
have Aids in a test tube because if we
hav't proven HIV causes AIDS
then can we show that what we're calling
HIV is an actual organism nobody has
actually purified HIV there's no little
bottle of HIV anywhere on the planet
that's just got HIV in it they have cell
lines that they think that it's growing
in there are a lot of people that think
it's not even there at all but I mean I
I wouldn't doubt that it's there I I
think anything you can imagine is there
somewhere you know but whether it's
there or not is not the question the
question is does it do anything thing
with regard to these set of diseases
that we've now called
AIDS all right there's another little
snippet
Martin so some infectious diseases were
actually just shortages of a vitamin
right yes we spoke earlier of scurvy
vitamin C now he spoke about nasin
deficiency in bread and children were
removed out of
houses and very soon there will be
legislation that if you do not receive a
certain
injection then you are not fit to be
amongst Society mhm now that is part of
History they have done it all along and
there have been many many tears and
eventually they came to the conclusion
that they were
wrong so what makes it so certain
Martin that the present generation is
the one that's right
correct or will a future generation find
out that they were possibly
wrong well if you take
history the record is not very good no
the record is not very good but you see
there are many
successes and if you see science
portrayed you always see these white
coats and these fancy labs and these
dispensers and they're very accurate
some of them you know they work in
microliters and even less than that and
you have very fancy machines and they're
beautiful machines chromatography
machines amino acid analyses I had all
of these machines they cost
millions in my Laboratories my students
were very acquainted with them I worked
with electron microscopes all the time a
university normally has one it's
normally located in one Department like
the physics department and all the other
departments use
it and so there are many things that you
can say right this is what it looks like
but when it comes to the level that he's
talking about like AIDS for
example there's no bottle which says
here it is correct doesn't
exist so it's purely based on
conjecture uh there's a lot of logic
behind it something is causing the
disease mhm something is causing the
disease and the prescribed treatment for
the disease can certainly kill you yeah
as he said
so uh if we don't have it in a
bottle and we don't know that it exists
other than it is probable that it exists
because something is making you sick
MH whereas in the previous cases that we
discussed it wasn't something that was
making you sick it was the absence of
something that was making you sick yes
right mhm so he's he's on the same page
here
and the
Cure that is
prescribed is deadly it's got a little
skull and crossbones on it it's
something that you don't want to put in
your
body and it might prevent
the immediate impact of whatever is
happening but sooner or later it gets
you yeah because it's treating the
symptoms and not the cause correct so
what if the cause is something else and
we don't really know we have a
theory is it a fact no no this is the
point but everyone you talk
to talks as if it is a fact we know mhm
we don't know here's the
Nobel Prize winner saying we don't know
do the scientists like him no no do we
see the same thing happen happening in
our day today well let me put it to you
this way time will tell time will tell
time discovered scurvy's problem yeah
P's problem you name it Poo's problem if
you look at the polio
issue and The Surge of polio in the
world it's F I find it fascinating
Martin that the polio increases
in Africa for example are very closely
correlated with the increases of the use
of DDT yes and when DDT was banned it
came down mhm and the decline is is
associated with
vaccine but is it possible that the
decline might be associated with
something else it's possible so if you
take many of the diseases in the
world and you compare vaccinated
countries with unvaccinated countries
for
example the vaccine was introduced at a
time when the problem was no longer
there correct because the decline not
only took place before the vaccines were
introduced in countries that were
vaccinated but also in areas that were
not vaccinated So what had changed why
did why did the numbers come down before
the vaccination and the vaccin gets the
credit when in actual fact it was better
nutrition that should get the the credit
in many
cases now what
increased the nutritional
value the development of the transport
system correct Martin the first train to
Roll Along The Rail lines in the United
States of America came in 1844 yeah
so if you wanted to get produce MH from
Mexico to the north of Canada you'd have
to get onto your horse and buggy yeah
and go and fetch it correct it will
never get there in time
correct so when the Transport Systems
opened up the markets opened up that
meant variety of food was available that
was never available before that meant
disease declined in areas atically then
someone discovered a vaccine introduced
it when the problem was already solved
yeah now people don't like that
information and some of the graphs are
literally
changed but the fact of the matter is
that most vaccines were introduced after
the problem had already been eradicated
yeah shall we continue with this
discussion
yes what what is it about human ity that
that that that wants to go to all the
details and stuff and listen you know
these guys like FY get up there and
start talking you know he does know
anything really about anything and I'd
say that to his face nothing the man
thinks you can take a blood sample and
stick it in an electron microscope and
if it's got a virus in there you'll know
it he doesn't understand electron
microscopy and he doesn't understand
medicine and he does he should not be in
a position like he's in most of those
guys up there on the top are just total
administrative people they don't know
anything about what's going on at the
bottom but you're talking about a
100,000 scientists who are making $6
billion this year more than on cancer
and heart disease combined you'll have
probably 5 to 15,000 studies written and
published over the next year and a half
to two years on this phenomena everyone
wants to be a part of that action why is
it there's only a small handful of
scientists like yourself and and um
Gilbert and duberg who are willing to
challenge
this what makes you different than
100,000 one thing that makes me
different is I don't have to answer to
anybody for money see I don't work for
some organization like that Tony fouchy
happens to be the head of like a lot of
people like duberg had the
intellectual uh Integrity knowing that
he was going to catch it knowing that
they were going to just have a Heyday
pulling his GRS he went ahead and said
it and he got he's basically he's been
martyred
you know I I think that money is the
main the only you know it's just like in
political scandals follow the money
Trail figure out who's getting paid for
this who's getting the money for those
Western blocks they've got a personal
kind of agenda they make up their own
rules as they go they change them when
they want to and they smugly like Tony
fouchy does not mind going on television
in front of the people that pay his
salary and lie directly into the
camera Martin that is a very
controversial statement that the man has
made mhm and uh he no longer is with us
so we can't ask him to give us more
reasons as to why he says something like
that but basically what he is
saying just because you have a position
in the CDC or in the World Health
Organization or wherever does that make
you the be all and the authority of
everything
no no and all also like he said that one
guy that was basically
martyred brings back to mind what you
mentioned earlier of that Dean yes he
was not prepared to be
martyred for no he wasn't prepared but
someu some are willing to stick their
neck out and stand for the truth even if
you're going to be ridiculed
right and uh I remember my first day
when
I sat in my
office and I thought of
Peter who had denied his Lord three
times and I had to go and do the
evolution discussion group with all the
postgrad students and the entire staff
present and I was this former atheist
fanatical
evolutionist and was I going to deny
him and keep my career and my
status or was I going to ask
some piercing
questions well I heard that Crow
and I
thought am I going to be a hypocrite all
my
life for the sake of my career
and I
decided I
won't and the rest is
history I've been spat on in my face in
front of hundreds of
students lecturer gets up comes to the
front spits in my face in front of them
all I've been sworn at I've been
ridiculed I've been shouted at I've had
it
all I remember the one case
where the
lecturer went into such a fit of rage it
was Indescribable he had a pile of books
in his hand he threw them on the ground
swore like a trooper and ran out of the
hall because the alternative was he had
to come and beat me up right yeah there
was deathly silence and the students
looked at me
and I said if you pick up a stone and
you throw it in a dark alley and a dog
Yelps it means you've hit
him that was
pandemonium but I can see what the man
is saying M you have these high placed
individuals who will Who will uh follow
the money Trail and if you look at some
of them I'm not saying that he's
definitely wrong on everything because
he's involved in the money Trail and
he's involved in the patents and the
research and all of that but that what
he says is it necessarily
true well there were quite a few things
that in a short period of time had to be
reversed okay so he's he the master of
reversal also
right and are there scientists that
vehemently disagree with him yes but his
position is such that he has the clout
behind him the we he has the we we have
decided and who are the we and why is it
that the we write articles in the
journal laet which they have to later
retract because they're basically lies
crazy isn't that correct isn't that what
happened doesn't that make you think
shouldn't you start wondering what's
going on in the world is science really
the new religion on the planet and what
one man says in a position of
authority when he shoves his little hand
into his pocket and says that he loves
the
Jesuits yeah is that going to make him
right maybe people must uh open their
eyes a little bit more maybe they must
open their eyes let's have a look look
at another one let's see what he has to
say he's a very interesting man yeah
when i s in
PCR no
thanks they rejected it nature rejected
PCR paper that I wrote and so did
science both of those auster magazines
but they took nature took the
cosmological significance of time
reversal which was the um sort of lunacy
of a of a of a sophomore I mean a second
year graduate student in Biochemistry
that that when that happened it really
that was my first real shock about
science I said there's nobody minding
the store you know there aren't any Wise
Old Men up there how could this
happen how could they let me publish
this theory in nature it's not like in
some Backwater journal Nature you know a
lot of the professors in the department
what in the hell is this one of our
graduate students just put his own paper
in nature and it's not even about
biochemistry the thing that I learned
like back in 1968 when I first published
a paper by myself in nature in a field
that I had no expertise in at all uh
there are no old wise men up there at
the top of science where which I would
have I really did until 68 I would have
thought you know if you try to publish a
dumb paper in a journal like nature it
won't get published if you try to
publish a good paper in there like I
later tried to published PCR the
invention of PCR in the same journal and
uh they didn't take it it's up there
there isn't up there there there's no
place up on the there's the Academy of
Science is just a bunch of idiots just
like everybody else you know the editors
of journals AER journals even they're
just busy with their little lives and
stuff there are no old wise men up on
the top making sure that we don't do
something really dumb an apple is an
apple you know you can get something
that's kind of like if you got enough
things that look kind of like an apple
and you stick them all together you
might think it it's an apple but and and
HIV is like that those tests are all
based on things that are invisible and
they are the results are inferred in a
sense PCR is separate from that it's
just a process that's used to make a
whole lot of something out of something
that's what it is but it's not it
doesn't tell you that you're sick and it
doesn't tell you that the thing you
ended up with really was going to hurt
you or anything like that that's so it's
not so even if you believe in hi it
can't tell the difference between virus
particles or active live virus I mean
there's a lot of questions
involved well Martin that gives you a
little bit more
insight now the very prestigious
journals out there are the journal
science in the United States of America
maybe Scientific American it's a little
bit more popular it's not quite on that
level and in the UK it would be the
journal
Nature and every scientist's dream is to
get a paper published in the journal
Nature and here this
man who later won the Nobel Prize
because of his invention couldn't get
his paper published in the journal
Nature but he wrote a silly little thing
when he was a student on cosmology which
was total nonsense according to him yeah
and they published
it so you know where are the criteria he
says there it's just like everything
else it uh it depends on your on your
situation and on the status and on
whatever is being said mhm what's the
norm being to now when we did our
research at my University one of my
students very very bright student he
became a
postdoc fellow at Harvard
University you don't achieve that
easily and and uh he was involved in
this this very controversial research
that we were doing on Dairy for example
you don't get to be a postdoc out of a
foreign country like South Africa at
Harvard for nothing right yeah and he
got there now he was my
student and uh this was my research and
he was the one that was taking it to a
PhD level right
and uh some of the results were so
stunning that I said to him we got to
publish this in
nature let's see let's write it up and
send it to Nature well they didn't take
it yeah no so and I don't feel so bad
now that Nobel Prize winner tells me
that they refused his paper as well yeah
but we got it published in the Journal
of uh patology so it got published but
it didn't get published in
nature but uh I can understand exactly
where it's coming from and how he thinks
if you don't have a particular mindset
how you going to get an article into the
Journal of paleontology for example now
I had a very interesting
situation I was lecturing at one of our
top universities in the country I
actually worked at that University as a
as a lecturer for a year uh before I
went to the university where I was the
professor University of the Western Cape
and uh I gave a lecture against the
theory of
evolution in fact in one of those
lectures I got spat
on so I've been there I've really been
there and I was speaking about the
Petrified
forests now I was explaining that they
that these forests weren't a model of
evolution at all because the
evolutionary theory says you know they
grew in Sito in those
places so these are
definitely proof of evolution because
those trees were petrified in their
position of
growth and uh this public a proved that
they were not that they were all washed
in that they were evidence of a flood
catastrophe yeah and that of course
freaked the theologists out so this guy
was thumping his desk and shouting at me
and screaming and then eventually he
said this rubbish would never be
published in any prestigious journal in
the
world now there have 400 students
sitting there right listening to
this and uh it's interesting in that in
that lecture one of the geologists from
another University got up and he looked
at these guys and he said to him you
know
what this this evidence is
overwhelming really guys if we want to
be true
scientists we have to take note and
rethink our
position do you think they said sure no
definitely there was a nuclear
explosion they nearly got into a fist
fight yeah and the students were doing
this in the end I was standing in the
front there and watching this
altercation taking place this is science
right
yeah and then he shouted at me and he
said this stuff would never get
published in a prestigious
journal and I said to him well excuse me
what Journal would you say is
prestigious when it comes to this
geological feature this paleontological
information he said the Journal of
paleontology that would be a
journal and I looked at him and I said
it's in
there and he looked at me and he shouted
he said you
[Applause]
liar and I said it'll be on your desk by
the morning
so I went home and I looked up where it
was I took the publication I made a copy
I went to his desk he wasn't there I put
it on his
desk and uh that evening I had another
lecture cuz these these lectures were
arranged after hours of course because
you know doesn't fit into the university
curriculum and uh he looked at me there
when I came in and I said well did you
find it on your dead
and he says yes but it says nothing
about the universal
flood so I said you're absolutely right
it says nothing about the universal
flood because if it would say that they
would never publish it in that journal
yeah so it's written in scientific
language just giving the facts and the
conclusion without adding any biblical
Criterion to it m and then it's
he said but that's not valid he says
that's cheating that's lying you should
have said what your philosophy is aha so
if you say the philosophy then the
journal won't take it correct if you
just give the facts the journal might
the the white coats up there might be
confused and take it right he's
absolutely right yeah I have experienced
it in my own life so to ostracize him
for what he says is to deny the truth
correct would you mind you you mentioned
that you when you decided okay you heard
the Crow you're going to walk in
there and if I remember correctly you
put down 10 questions yes would you mind
sharing with us maybe one two or three
questions that you put down there for
those students well that's quite a tall
order yeah let's let's I can talk about
one or two of them we're talking about
Evolution right and the theory of
evolution and how it
works and uh at that stage I was
lecturing to the medical
students and I was uh teaching them
genetics
mhm so you were
actually training medical students
amongst others yes I was in the zoology
Department I was a comparative phys
ologist that was my speciality that was
my research so I was working on animals
I was working on the endocrine system
mhm the hormonal system okay so I
compared the hormonal uh system of
viviparity
livebearing pregnancy if you like with
of
fishes how they work reptiles how they
work mammals MH how they work and uh I
didn't use humans as guinea
pigs but uh I was testing the endocrine
system I'm off the topic now but just
for interest sake for our our critics
who like to say zoologist you
know uh I could say I was an
endocrinologist my PhD was largely on
endocrinology and electromicroscopy and
auto radiography which is
biochemistry so you know it it gets very
confusing out there and uh uh you know
uh the Layman will think he knows how
many scales there are on the back of a
of a lizard but that's not what this is
all
about so my research was on all of these
animals and I was testing the the
hormonal
Cascades one of the hormones that uh
maintains pregnancy is the hormone
progesterone so progesterone is a
hormone that is produced by the Corpus
lithium which is after the the ovary has
a follicle in a follicular stage where
estrogen is in the ascendancy and then
it is transformed after pregnancy after
that ovam is ejected it is transformed
into a corpus lithium which produces
another Cascade of of endocrine products
the most prominent being the
progestins and so I wanted to know okay
so mamalian systems uh maintain their
pregnancy using progesterone what what
does the fish do you see some fish lay
eggs but some fish are livebearing yeah
uh some fish are over vorous some are
vorous the over vorous means that
they're basically Al have eggs but
they're just retained in the body and
vorus means that they have to be
nurtured in the body not in the form of
an egg but directly by some form of
integration like a placenta or something
similar so I was working on that which
is a very tricky thing to do because if
you're working with a mammal depending
on what kind of mammal you're working
with uh will determine how much blood
you can extract without killing the
animal right yeah yeah
so uh if you're working on a mouse or a
rat if you can get a mill milliliter of
blood then you're taking quite a lot
compared to the size of the animal if
you're working on a
lizard then you're you're working in
microliters right yeah if you're working
with a human you can take a half a liter
yeah and uh you know if you're working
with hormones that's a very uh that's a
molecule in very small
quantities so I had to actually adapt
the
techniques at the stage where where we
were working many of these techniques
were were new and they all work with
radiometrics so they with radioactive
materials so that you can trace how much
of a particular hormone there is and so
I had to change the mechanisms and the
research abilities to to accommodate
micro levels of blood in order to
determine whether there was anything
like it and you could show then that the
Cascade in a fish is very similar to
that of in a mouse okay so that's very
interesting right and uh there are
little differences little Nuance
differences but if you know what the
fish Works how he works and you know how
the reptile works I worked on chameleons
on the endocrine system of chameleon
that was my Master's Degree and uh Then
I then I transitioned to Auto
radiography electron microscopy and ver
parity in fishes and later I did
research on on rats and hamsters on
rabbits on veret monkeys on you name it
on domestic animals on pigs on sheep you
name it the whole lot so it gives you a
very broad
spectrum but I'm off the topic what was
your question no my question was what
your question was what did I say yeah
all right so I was teaching genetics
that's how we got into it right I was
teaching genetics to the medical
students and uh I was sitting and
thinking about the theory of evolution
in
genetics and in
genetics we
know that the gene
system the genome determines your
characteristics it's your blueprint
right yes and the the genetic system is
extremely
complicated because you have structural
genes which determine the structure of
particular proteins which Drive
particular uh reactions in your body and
some proteins actually form part of the
structure like muscle proteins
Etc and this this complexity in the
genetic system is absolutely astounding
how it works and the Integrity thereof
and if you look at the process of U
replication
during the myotic process when cells
divide then you have to divide the DNA
right and it has to be a very precise
Pro process where you have to make a
blueprint so basically it's like taking
this book
Martin and saying okay the words in this
book are written in a particular
sequence and only when they're written
in the sequence does it make sense right
so when this is your blueprint in your
cell and you're making a copy of this
cell then you have to copy this
blueprint mhm but now if you take the
letter here I'm opening it at random and
it says and King David said call me
zadok the priest and Nathan the
prophet now if that were a code a DNA
code and it worked in triplets in three
determining an amino acid and I read
Aunt King David said call me zadok the
priest then I would have to read it as a
triplet code
and
VI and not Han the
prop hit and Ben Etc you get it cuz I'm
reading reading it now in threes now now
what if I miss a letter uhhuh instead of
reading and King David call me I would
read
hinted it would become gibberish yeah
all right so it has to be exact so you
have to make a copy of this an exact
repli replica you you miss one letter
yeah it's a total
disaster and the mechanisms that ensure
that it is precise
are so
complicated you have a enzyme that runs
along the genetic system and
reads what I've just read yeah
Genetically speaking now and then has to
make an exact replica a
copy are you with me yeah yeah so that's
what happens in in your DNA when you're
replicating it and you have this this
replicas enzyme going
at tremendous speed because you have
thousands of
genes and let's say escoria coli which
is a bacterium in your stomach now in
your
intestine has to replicate within 20
minutes yeah that means he has to read
his book and rewrite it and copy it
within 20 minutes without a mistake
otherwise the next generation is not
going to be eoli it's going to be
something else right yeah yeah
complicated yeah so when you have that
one enzyme running along you have at
least five of them going after with
behind it which are called edit tasers
yeah checking that the editing is
correct and if there is a mistake they
retract all the way back and rewrite it
so that the mistake is corrected okay so
once you start going into the
nitty-gritty of how it works and now
we're only talking structural genes
when you're talking about controlling
genes which make up the the bulk of your
genetic system that's why it's so
ridiculous to give an example like o the
chimpanzee has
98% correlation between their DNA and
ours and that is the most ridiculous
statement under the sun because how the
genes are controlled is more important
about than actually what they say
yeah and uh to put that in in simple
language let's say the keys on a
piano are the jeans yeah right that's
one thing and I can goink plink plink
blinkink
blinkink on the piano yeah that's not
music no that's plinky
plink right mhm how do you make music
out of that have to know you have to to
use various combinations yeah right and
you have to use them with PA and you
have to use them with intelligence and
you have to use them you know in the
most amazing fashion and you sit at
those same keys that
go all the way up and you
go you make the most amazing
music that's the controlling genes
deciding what the music's going to be
right mhm so using the same Keys you can
get
chaikovsky and you can get rock and roll
depending on what you want to play right
exactly so the genetic system is so
complicated that these white coats
haven't got the foggiest idea of what
they're playing talking about it's like
really I'm being a little bit factious
now but if you have discovered
Martin by looking at at a
piano that the keys are on a particular
order have you got the foggiest idea
about music at that stage no
no this is what we're at correct all
right so now we' have to discovered what
the sequence of the DNA is that's like
someone saying I know in which order the
keys on the piano are and you haven't
got the foggiest idea how to play the
thing correct right mhm that's
science now we're talking science now
I'm talking like that guy and I'll
probably written off and thrown to the
thrown to the dogs
okay so
complicated the next question which begs
to be answered is how did it come into
existence right correct this complex
system that has to work like
clockwork that has so many
complicated mechanisms to ensure perfect
replication and The evolutionary
Paradigm says that natural selection
doesn't work at the level of the
genotype it only works at the level of
the phenotype MH are you with me mhm now
the
phenotype is what you look like all
right so if I had to describe
you uh let's not do that because I will
be
naughty but let's just say you're
shorter than me yeah correct yes that
doesn't necessarily mean that I run
faster but the probability that I with
longer legs can could have run faster if
I were your age pretty high right yeah
okay so natural selection Works what is
there
natural
selection doesn't know what's written in
this book you only know what's written
in this book once you see it there you
are so that we call your phenotype
natural selection works on the level of
the phenotype it doesn't work on the
level of the actual
information so how did the information
come into existence by chance Yeah by
chance so you mean to tell me Martin
that this book with all its
information fell out of the sky one day
and it was complete and made
sense it couldn't be modified by The
evolutionary process because natural
selection doesn't work at the level of
the genotype it only works at the level
of the
phenotype let me explain that
differently if I want to know which
Aeroplane flies
best of two different models what do I
have to do compare the two and go fly
them yeah fly them and see which one
works right normally you use something
called a test pilot and he gets paid an
exorbitant amount of money because he
doesn't know what he's going to get out
of that box alive right okay so if I
want to know which plane flies best I
have to go and test them gri does it
answer the question where did the planes
come from no okay where did the planes
come from from from the factory from the
factory okay who built the
airplane szo right
uh okay the fact that you built it
still means nothing who designed it
designer it takes an a designer an
engineer right so there's a heck of a
process now when that
engineer went and designed it did he
make the
drawings and did he work out the
aerodynamics did he use the mathematics
associated with it did he use lift and
force and this and that and all that
information yes okay and then he wrote
it in the
book and he said here's the procedure of
how to build this
airlane okay yeah now if I give you the
book with the procedure how to build the
airplane M you and I have the book fly
the
airplane yeah now you have to get into
to it and fly it can you fly the book no
no what must you do with the book build
the aerplane
use this to build the a so you what do
you need you need an interpreter of what
it says you need an interpreter and you
need the mechanism to build the aerplane
correct okay so the book had to come
about by chance in evolution because
there's no
designer right came about by chance with
a blueprint yeah plus the mechanism to
transfer the blueprint into the product
and until you get the product natural
selection doesn't
work so given the complexity of the
situation what is the probability Martin
that this book without a designer fell
from the sky one day with its blueprint
what's the probability zero
okay it's zero all right now even if it
fell from the sky and there
lies what's the probability that the
mechanism to read what it says and to
trans further information into an actual
product meaning that you must get the
raw materials that you must get the
sequence and to produce the raw
materials plus you must bend the raw
materials into the shape that they have
to be so that they have eyes and the
nose and teeth and everything that is in
you which is incredibly complicated even
you take a simple cell yeah where did
that come from also by chance by
chance so I asked my students and my
audience what is the probability of that
happening and how much Faith do you
need how much Faith do you need to
believe
it and that caused Mayhem I can imagine
that was one of the questions
that was one of the questions it caused
mayem wow to the extent that one of the
students got
up a young lady she was doing her honors
degree BSC Bachelor of Science
honors and she looked around the hall
and she said when I came to this
University I was a believing Christian
and now that I'm an honest student and
I've been
through the Bachelor of Science degree
and I'm now studying Bachelor of Science
honors degree I've become an
atheist and
now I am told that you lied to
me do you think that went down well no
he mm no it didn't go down well didn't
go down well well for my career
either I'm
sure yes but that's how it is and that's
I'm sure it's not only in The
evolutionary science department when
after leaving the university after this
debacle you know what the debacle was
Martin a conflict between truth and
error yes that's what the debacle was
and when I left the university because
of the debacle of Tru truth and
error I believe that God in his
Mercy reinstated me back in the
university and I became the professor
and
head of a department of zoology MH as a
comparative physiologist within that
department and I became the head of that
department which is a miracle being an
creationist right yeah
and I received in the end that Grant
from the Royal Society for
reconstruction and
development and uh a a massive research
program that as I said resulted in
postdoc Harvard students right yes so uh
now God had a plan God had a plan
correct and when I started the
research on nutrition correct
do you think that it was plain sailing
or do you think that the same opposition
that I received on the level of
evolution that I received the same
opposition on the basis of nutrition
definitely so
Martin my question to you is this is the
world being fed a bunch of Lies when it
comes to
nutrition if they were fed a bunch of
lies on The evolutionary track I'm sure
because probably in nutrition they also
use evolutionary theories okay now our
illustrious scientist scientist
basically alluded to the fact that you
can follow the money
Trail right
yes and the PCR
tests right mhm so it's a polymerase
test that enhances whatever is there
yeah so it takes something smaller and
it makes it
big and many of these tests cannot be
used what they are being used for that's
why they give false positives or false
negatives he actually said at one stage
that you can test for AIDS and it'll
give you a positive test and you can
test again tomorrow and it might give
you a negative test because they're
using some of the tests that are
developed for the various diseases in in
a way that it shouldn't be used but for
every test there's a money Trail yes and
for every positive test there's a super
money Trail because thousands of dollars
get funneled into these
organizations for the
governments that run on positive tests
that's it so if you can make a test
mandatory and force 7 billion people to
take a test and you put that into
terms there are the people that have the
patents that get a cut there are a
people that the people that prescribe
the test that get a cut they are the
people that produce the test that get a
cut they are the people that oversee
like the the CDC Etc they get a cut and
the scientists that are involved they
get the huge salaries as a consequence
of that cut can you see this this can be
a very use thing correct and the more
positives you have the better for the
money trial
mhm I can definitely see it did he say
that some of the medication can
certainly kill you yes all right now I'm
a scientist
Martin and I can
understand that sometimes a medication
that can kill
you might be useful if it also kills the
disease before it kills you and he said
something so similar right like
chemotherapy for example it's definitely
bad for you and if you take it for a
long time it'll kill you yes but the
hope is as he said that it'll kill the
bad guy in you before it kills the good
guy in you so the bad cell the cancer
cell dies before you and then you you
get over it
right now we know today that a large
proportion of cancer is based on
lifestyle diseases yes the statistics
tell you that that's it so a correction
of
Lifestyle would be a better
alternative than the other right but
there are also genetic implications and
the young child can get it and life is
is not
fair and uh some people have a weak
Constitution some have a stronger
Constitution some are more predisposed
genetically than others there are many
many
factors I'm not against using a
medication that will kill a disease
even though it's bad for you if the
natural alternative will take longer
than the disease takes to kill
you in other words if the disease is
going to kill you in 7
days and a natural cure will help you in
10 days that's too late
mhm but if a product will kill the
disease in two days even though it's bad
for you it can save your life so I'm not
anti-science but many many drugs no
matter what they are will do something
to you which is detrimental yes it might
save your life for a while but it'll
come out in another way so here is a
quote that I would like to
read comes from the spirit of Prophecy
how to
live drugs never cure
disease they only change its form and
location when drugs are introduced into
the system for a time they seem to have
a beneficial effect a change might take
place but the disease is not cured it
will manifest itself in some other form
the disease which the drug was given to
cure may disappear but only to reappear
in a new form such as the skin disease
ulcer painful disease joints and
sometimes in a more dangerous and deadly
form nature keeps struggling and the
patient suffers with different ailments
until there is a sudden breaking down of
her efforts and death
follows many kind times
Martin well all the time if you take the
little pamphlet
out from the little drug that you have
just received from the pharmacy
the list of side
effects is so long and so daunting that
you dare not read it because you will
not swallow that stuff if you read it
right yeah it's happened to me quite
often or quite a few times okay so once
you start understanding this
principle avoidance and treatment of the
cause by correcting whatever it is that
your body requires it manifests it
itself in the form of a
disease is a better option to go correct
sometimes sometimes as I said it can
happen that the nature of the disease
requires another intervention I'm not
against that but the logical thing to do
is
to try and do the best you can to give
yourself the best best environment to be
healthy in the best medicine is good
food correct that is the best medicine
and it's important we will in a future
discussion talk about that because
there's a big war going on on what is
good food exactly so we need to talk
about that issue so for our
viewers we're not against
science but we are against science
falsely so called called correct I have
a serious problem with many of the
philosophies of
Science and I have a very serious
problem with the we of
science so may God give us the
wisdom and uh this was basically an
introduction into our discussion on
health it seems to work out this way our
introductions turn out to be lectures we
must stop this
nonsense but it just a fact that this is
how it works if we start understanding
the issue yeah then maybe we can make
informed choices oh definitely and then
maybe the
position that we stand for will not look
so ridiculous I hope so let's pray
thanks heavenly
father thank
you that you have
penned in a book where we come from
and that you have penned in a book where
we are
going and that you have given us a road
map of how to get
there but we have a stubborn
nature and tend to want to find our own
path and it takes pain and suffering
sometimes to bring us to our
senses I believe that that which can
happen on the individual level is
happening on a universal scale and the
whole of
humanity will have to decide between the
veracity of two religious
systems wearing white
coats help us to make good decisions in
jesus' name amen amen
[Music]